bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 politique une édition
largement consacrée aux élections
régionales de décembre prochain vous
entendrez deux têtes de liste en île de
france aujourd'hui pierre laurent pour
le front de gauche le leader du parti
communiste et et à saint quentin en
yvelines il ya quelques jours pour une
conférence avec les étudiants de
l'université et puis en plateau françois
asselineau le fondateur de l'upm lui
aussi est candidat en ile de france et
puis enfin d'édition nous reviendrons
aussi sur le déplacement de 18 ministres
aux mureaux pour l'annoncé de plusieurs
mesures en faveur des banlieues
première invitée du 7-8 politique
aujourd'hui donc françois asselineau
bonjour et bienvenue sur ce plateau je
vous êtes le président de l'upm l'union
populaire républicaine tête de liste
pour les régionales en île de france
avant de se pencher sur vos propositions
quelques éléments de présentation vous
avez fait hec et l'ena vous avez
travaillé dans différents cabinets de
ministres dans le gouvernement d'alain
juppé vous avez été aussi et directeur
chargé des affaires économiques et
internationales au conseil général des
hauts-de-seine c'était sous la
présidence de charles pasqua au début
des années 2000 première adhésion à un
parti politique
en 99 c'est le rpf le rassemblement pour
la france de pasqua justement mais ces
idées ne vont pas assez loin pour vous
vous qui souhaitez sortir de la
construction européenne de l'union
européenne de l'euro également
et puis vous dénoncez une influence
anglo-saxonne américaine sur la france
aujourd'hui vous êtes crédité entre 0 et
1% d'intentions de vote en ile de france
quelle est votre ambition sur ce scrutin
m'a d'abord merci de m'inviter
là je note qu'il est vous avez éprouvé
le besoin de rappeler ce qu'étaient lui
paie c'est une véritable anomalie en
définitive puisque notre mouvement
politique est actuellement le mouvement
qui se développe le plus en france sur
internet et par le bouche à oreille nous
avons dépassé enfin nous sommes en train
de dépasser les 9000 adhérents c'est
beaucoup ça fait deux fois le nombre
d'adhérents de élevé par exemple celle
d'une base sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment pressé active absolument et
nous nous sommes présentés l'année
dernière aux élections européennes
au niveau national nous avons fait 0 41%
des suffrages dont 0 57% d'ailleurs en
ile de france cette année depuis le 1er
janvier nous nous sommes présentés à
quinze élections 14 élections
départementales une élection législative
partielle
on a fait une moyenne de 1,7 pour cent
donc nous ne sommes plus un mouvement
totalement marginal oussama mouvement en
forte croissance ce qui n'est pas normal
c'est que nous ne sommes jamais sur les
grands médias du pays je vous remercie
de tout ça en tout cas venu en plateau
dénoncer tout à l'heure tout de même les
fondements de l'upm sortir de l'europe
dénoncer la mainmise américaine alors on
vous présente souvent dans les médias
aussi peut-être pour ça vous dit que
vous n'êtes pas d'invités comme un
complotiste un partisan de la théorie du
complot vous dit par exemple que c'est
la cia qui a créé l'europe ça c'est tout
à fait justifié j'invite d'ailleurs les
téléspectateurs à aller sur le site une
paire point fr qui le site de notre
mouvement politique et qui d'ailleurs
est l'un des deux sites de partis
politiques les plus consultés de france
c'est très important vous parler de
complot ne sommes pas des complotistes
mais je vais quand même vous signaler
quelque chose d'intéressant dans la
version de charles de gaulle de la
constitution de 1958 dans l'article 68
il était question de complot contre la
sûreté de l'état et de crime de haute
trahison qui pouvait être imputé au
président de la république eh bien vous
savez que ces deux crimes ont été
retirés de la constitution française
dans le dos des français par deux
réformes constitutionnelles il faut pas
voir une idée derrière la tête de votre
avis pour retirer ces deux éléments pour
en revenir à votre formation politique
comment voyager c'est lorsqu'on vous dit
que vous vous êtes complot tiges ont dit
que non non on dit simplement à les voir
aller voir toutes les preuves qui sont
justifiées qui sont présentés sur le sur
le vul sur le site
surtout ça sont des éléments d'actualité
des imans d'histoire qui sont tout à
fait justifiées mais 2015 sur beur fm
vous déclarez la vie politique française
et vitrifié il ya des choses qu'on n'a
pas le droit de dire enfants voilà il ya
des choses ces choses là par exemple on
n'a pas le droit de dire qu'il y ait un
article il s'appelle l'article 50 du
traité de l'union européenne qui permet
de sortir de l'union européenne
unilatéralement sereinement et
juridiquement on n'a pas le droit de
dire qu'il ya un article 13 du traité de
l'atlantique nord qui permet de sortir
de l'otan voilà ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de dire on n'a pas le droit de
dire non plus que tout les monnaie
supranationale comme l'euro se sont
toujours toujours exposés dans
l'histoire voilà ce que l'on n'a pas le
droit de dire
pour qu'on appellera de le dire parce
que c'est comme ça moi je suis invitée
parce que là vous êtes là vous le dites
c'est voilà oui mais merde oui mais que
pourquoi est-ce que je ne suis pas
invité sur les médias de grande
diffusion c'est une vraie question c'est
une vraie question que vous vous posez
vous avez j'imagine
nous avons écouté nous avons contacté de
très très nombreux journalistes très
grand de très grande notoriété qui nous
ont toujours dit que voilà
malheureusement ils ne pouvaient pas
nous inviter voilà c'est dommage parce
que les formations politiques c'est
d'être crédité autour de 1 ou 2 %
d'expliquer justement qu'elles ne sont
pas assez
attendez il le problème qu'il va y avoir
pour les élections régionales c'est que
on n'en veut pas mais vous savez qu'il
va être le premier gagnant ça fait les
abstentionnistes il ay avoir sans doute
40-50 peut-être plus %
d'abstentionnistes
comme tous les sondages montrent les
vrais sondages que les français ne
veulent plus entendre parler de la
plupart des mouvements politiques ni
tête qui connaissent ils veulent du
nouveau quand on leur présente un
mouvement nouveau d'un seul coup tous
les médias se ferme il y à un véritable
verrouillage si le média jouer le rôle
il donnerait la parole à des mouvements
et en particulier le doute puisque nous
développons extrêmement rapidement sur
internet
ça veut bien dire que les conférences
qui sont en ligne sur le site huppert
point fr intéresse beaucoup les joueurs
j'ai fait une conférence qui s'appelle
qui gouvernait la france on en est à
bientôt 280 mille visionnages c'est
comme beaucoup quand vous dites vous
déplorez développer beaucoup pardon sur
sur internet s'adressera trouvaient
aussi dans les urnes on savait bien
qu'aussi sur internet il ya toujours
possibilité à se retrouver les chiffres
ça se retrouve sur non ça se retrouve
dans les urnes je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure on est passé de 0,4 à 1,7
mais évidemment mais là je passe pour
une fois mais comment voulez vous que
les gens que les flics et les électeurs
votent pour un mouvement politique dont
ils n'ont jamais entendu parler je suis
mieux persuader que parmi vous
téléspectateurs l'yonne en ce moment
même qui nous découvrent le p r qui se
réclament ni de droite ni de gauche
comme le front national
vous demandez la sortie nord de l'europe
vous à votre adversaire direct c'est
quoi c'est le front national justement
debout la france s'était mais permettez
moi de corriger ce n'est pas que nous
nous réclamons denis le trading on sait
que le ministère de l'intérieur a
examiné notre nos analyses et nos
trélazé en liste divers nous sommes
classés en listes diverses parce que
notre problème s'inspire du conseil
national de la résistance de 1944 bien
entendu mis au goût du jour c'était par
exemple je voulais revenir à la défense
des services publics à la française
nous voulons défendre les acquis sociaux
des ouvriers les salariés et nous
présenter une précision
que les problèmes auxquels sont
confrontés les français découle
directement de notre appartenance à
l'union européenne et à l'euro voilà ce
qui nous distingue entre autres choses
du reste quant à front national puisque
vous évoquez le différencie de glace
d'abord le front national où la france
également le bout la france où le front
national je paye j'offre une caisse de
six bouteilles de champagne tout
téléspectateur qui pourra me présenter
une profession de foi vous savez le
document qui d'emblée à tous les
électeurs où le front national ou bien
dès leur proposerait aux électeurs de
sortir de l'union européenne par
l'article 50 et de sortir de l'otan ils
ne le font pas ce sont les journalistes
qui disent qu'ils sont contre l'union
européenne va pour taper sur l'europe
ils sont très forts mais vous dites que
vous êtes le seul à vouloir sortir de
l'europe
bonjour vous laisse vous avez absolument
et nous le ferons lorsque nous serons
élus en effet on va revenir tout de même
régional pour le programme et les
européennes la question européenne a une
incidence sur sur les régions parce que
ce qui se dessine si on lit votre
programme ce sont les eurorégions
administré directement par bruxelles
voilà c'est nous sommes le seul
mouvement politique d'ailleurs à mettre
en garde les français c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinairement grave ce qui
se passe c'est que l'on veut pourquoi
par exemple et veux-t-on supprimer les
départements les les français ne veulent
pas je le gardais les départements c'est
une création de révolution française qui
assure l égalité entre les territoires
et entre les français pourquoi est ce
que l'on nous impose une fusion sorti
d'un chapeau d'un certain nombre de
grandes régions ça ne concerne pas
l'ile-de-france mais nous présentons des
listes dans toutes les régions
pourquoi est ce que l'on veut aux
agrégés les communes nous nous sommes le
seul mouvement qui expliqueront pourquoi
ce dont il s'agit c'est en réalité de
données de plus en plus de pouvoir à des
grandes régions en leur disant vous
allez traiter directement avec bruxelles
et puis dans cinq ans ou dans dix ans et
puis on dira finalement ben le niveau de
la république française n'a plus
d'intérêt on va créer les états unis
d'europe et ça sera la dislocation de la
france ce n'est pas ce que je vais
revenir alors marc keller sur la
question du complot la non mais pas
jeter sur des jaunes a toujours regardé
ce qui se passe il faut regarder ce qui
se passe ailleurs regardez ce qui se
passe en espagne en espagne où la
catalogne lui réclame son indépendance
dans plein de l'union européenne
regardez ce qui se passe au royaume uni
où les costes réclame son indépendance
dans le cadre de l'union européenne
notez d'ailleurs que ces indépendances
sont des indépendances pour rire les
indépendantistes écossais ont dit que
s'il avait obtenu l'indépendance la
première chose qu'il ferait s'est
installé une base de l'otan en écosse et
tout s'est tous
vous imaginez bien que lundi on apprend
les sauces sur la région ile de france
vous avez bien vous comprenez bien avec
un pays comme la france qui a déjà
beaucoup de difficulté à résister au
rouleau compresseur euro atlantistes
s'il était morcelée c'est terminé donc
ce qu'il y a une véritable pensée
géostratégique qui est derrière et
comment elle a le droit de prévoir 5 ans
10 ans avance la pensée géostratégique
et derrière c'est la création
d'etats-unis d'euros amérique si j'ose
dire
dirigé par l'onudc de washington est ce
qui explique d'ailleurs ce qui est
négocié dans le dos du peuple français
qui est le traité transatlantique nous
nous opposons fermement à la signature
du traité transatlantique lorsqu on vous
entend on comprend bien que c'est tout
c'est tous ses programmes toutes ces
choses que vous mettez en avant ça
dépasse le cadre des régionales là vous
préparer concrètement le scrutin
présidentiel mais attendez les autres
les autres partis il faut arrêter de se
raconter des histoires le soir du
premier tour à 20h et rhône et trente
secondes on parlera plus des programmes
on dira est ce que le parti socialiste a
fait un bon score et si la ferme bleue
au score ça sera interprété ce site une
fois qu'on est élu avec un soutien comme
ceci dit quand on est élu il faut aussi
mettra en oeuvre les propositions qu'on
a pu faire et la région a des
compétences malgré tout les compétences
et le développement économique par
exemple l'aménagement du territoire
quelles sont vos propositions concrètes
dans ce domaine alors sur le
développement économique j'entendais
madame pécresse qui vient on va
développer l'emploi et se moque du monde
la création d'emplois c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
la création de l'emploi c'est géré par
le budget de l'état et parle de taux de
change externe de la monnaie et par le
taux d'intérêt tous ceux ci sont des
compétences qui sont ont été transférés
à bruxelles et à francfort
c'est pour ça que nous nous sommes le
parti qui disons français pourquoi quand
ils votent à droite quand ils votent à
gauche ils ont en fait toujours la même
politique
alors nous nous avons un programme pour
la région un problème par exemple on
parle du grand pareil et bien sûr le
grand paris nous nous proposons qu'il y
ait un référendum pas seulement en ile
de france que sur des très grands
projets d'infrastructures on demande aux
populations ce qu'elles veulent et sur
le grand paris par exemple vous pourriez
le supprimer et vous trouvez que c'est
une bonne ou mauvaise idée sur le grand
paris d'abord on en réalise ça
n'intéresse pas énormément les gens en
définitive ceux ci dans 20 30 ans quand
les infrastructures seront construites
sa famille l'attendait tout le monde est
favorable à développer les le transport
de banlieue à banlieue tout le monde est
favorable
a augmenté à améliorer les transports
tout le monde et doivent la france par
exemple nicolas dupont aignan dit qu'il
arrêtera ce projet oui mais bon ça c'est
monsieur dupont-aignan lui prend cette
décision nous nous prenons voulait pas
prendre de décisions 10 et aux
franciliens de se décider
nous on fera un référendum en disant aux
franciliens qu'est ce que vous voulez on
leur présentera trois ou quatre projets
et à vous de décider si nous voulons
rétablir la démocratie
je suis pas con et je vous interromps
mais on peut pas toujours décidés par
des référendums bien entendu il faut
aussi mais attendez là je parle du grand
paris sont des jeux olympiques ce jeu je
parle de choses qui sont massives
il est bien entendu que les élus
négocier enfin voteront au moment du
vote du budget les élus de l'upm
voteront le budget abdou grand d
inflexion vers tel ou tel domaine
il ya quelque chose aussi que je
voudrais dire c'est que l'épargné tous
les partis qui se présentent ou à peu
près vont dire voilà on va faire on va
mettre l'accent là dessus ou là dessus
nous ce que nous explique on sait que la
construction européenne elle a un impact
direct immédiat sur la question des
régions pourquoi c'est parce que vous
savez que l'état a été contraint par la
commission européenne de faire 50
milliards d'euros d'économies et c'est
la raison pour laquelle l'état est en
train de faire des coupes sombres dans
les dotations globales de fonctionnement
qui sont donnés aux collectivités
territoriales en particulier à la région
ile-de-france boxe que nous nous disons
c'est que il y a une grande incohérence
de la part des partis européistes d'être
à la fois pour le maintien dans l'euro
le maintien le respect du pacte
budgétaire et puis par ailleurs au
niveau régional de dire on va dépenser
si on va dépenser donc vous vous dites
quoi pour les électeurs aujourd'hui qui
seraient intéressés pour voter pour
votre liste vous leur proposez quoi vous
fait pas de propositions parce qu'on n'a
pas en l'espace de quelques minutes je
les aime être difficile je n'ai pas
l'occasion de développer tout ça je les
renvoie sur notre site huppert pendant
tout l'été sur la question de
l'éducation par exemple juste pour
conclure parce qu'on va arriver au terme
de cet entretien sur l'éducation si une
compétence importante
l'aménagement des lycées aussi par
exemple l'apprentissage ou l'importance
d'une complètement vidé région wallonne
nous mettons le paquet sur le sur
l'artisanat qui est le premier employeur
de france
nous voulons mettre le paquet et
figurant sur la rénovation des lycées
nous ne sommes absolument pas d'accord
avec madame pécresse qui veut mettre le
oui
le 4g dans les lycées parce que madame
pécresse elle confond elle confond la
vie la vie dans la rue avec
l'instruction publique
nous nous voulons que justement les
lycées soit un espèce dans un endroit où
préservé où l'on donne aux élèves
l'instruction qu'ils n'ont pas parce
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'enseigner aux
jeunes d'utiliser une tablette ça c'est
pas vrai du tout en notant avoir
internet dans les établissements
scolaires on peut avoir internet
alyotech mais le 4g peuvent vous
imaginez un professeur pendant qu'il
fait des coups avec tous ces élèves qui
sont avec la tablette bon c'est se
moquer du monde
c'est pas le ski se met en place dans
beaucoup de pays et c'est ce qui se met
en place au siège et alors pourquoi il
sait bien le problème actuellement des
jeunes c'est justement de savoir
raisonnée pour avoir un bel emploi ils
disent qu'il faut il faut bien parler le
français l'écrire correctement savoir
raisonnée avoir des humanités et ça
c'est justement l'instruction publique
qui le donne ça n'est pas ce n'est pas
internet internet il suffit de sortir du
lycée pour la voir partout voilà quelle
est la réalité
merci françois asselineau vous êtes
président de l'upm l'union populaire
républicaine tête de liste pour ces
élections régionales en île de france
est revenu sur notre plateau nous
continuons à parler de ces régionales en
île de france justement le modem qui a
décidé de se rallier à la liste les
républicains de valérie pécresse pour
ces régionales françois bayrou qui avait
soutenu françois hollande lors de la
dernière profiler présidentiel qui
continue donc à oeuvrer pour un
rapprochement du centre et de la droite
au départemental également les deux
formations avaient joué la carte de
l'alliance en marge d'un déplacement à
versailles pour l'enregistrement d'une
émission de radio vous voyez nous sommes
allés recueillir les explications de
l'actuel maire de pau c'est au micro de
huitième et demi d'eau
si on veut obtenir des résultats quand
on est assez proches les uns des autres
c'est bien de pouvoir s'accorder et
valérie pécresse c'est quelqu'un dont je
pense que qu'elle a ce qu'il faut pour
conduire une alliance de de cet ordre à
condition qu'elles soient équilibrés
mais je pense que c'est un plus qui est
cette
ce rassemblement jean pierre laurent
bonjour secrétaire nationale du parti
communiste est tête de liste pour ces
régionales en île de france sous
l'étiquette du front de gauche vous êtes
venus échanger avec les étudiants
aujourd'hui ici vous qui avez été
d'ailleurs militants étudiants
communistes quelques sujets vous
appréciez la tâche et changer comme ça
justement dans les universités avec les
plus jeunes oui bien sûr d'une part
parce que en ile de france la question
du développement
publieront et la jeunesse d'une manière
générale c'est un enjeu majeur dans une
région qui est très dynamique de ce
point de vue là mais dans lequel il ya
un besoin de politiques publiques très
forte est aujourd'hui une grande pénurie
par rapport aux énormes besoins qu'il
existe donc la région a une grande
responsabilité et moi en plus ça me
permet de me confronter à la jeunesse
d'île de france
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire et
beaucoup d'idées c'est ce que je
constate à chaque fois que je vais dans
une fac ou à la rencontre de jeunes dans
les quartiers
la thématique d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'université une université mise à mal
ce que vous nous dites notamment dans le
cadre de la loi pécresse la loi
d'autonomie des universités là on est au
coeur des régionales valérie pécresse
qui aujourd'hui représentent les
républicains dans cette campagne
vous êtes venus la combattre sur cette
mesure qu'elle avait mises en place oui
parce que le monde de l'université
aujourd'hui frappée doublement à la fois
par les politiques d'austérité qui
frappe leur ensemble des politiques
publiques et au même temps elle subit
les conséquences directes de la loi mis
en place par pécresse qui avait prétendu
qu en accordant l'autonomie de
financement et
gestion université une voie royale
allait s'ouvrir vers des moyens nouveaux
pour l'université et aujourd'hui on sait
que ça aboutit à la mise en difficulté
très profonde de toute une série
d'université en ile de france et
ailleurs et on assiste à des
regroupements universitaires qui pose
beaucoup de problème du point de vue de
la qualité de l'enseignement de
l'encadrement des étudiants de la vision
aussi qu'on a de 2d des contenus
d'enseignement
donc on est dans une situation un peu
alarmante
alors même que le potentiel
universitaire et de recherche dans l'île
de france est considérable et qu'on
devrait miser à fond sur cette carte là
et on le fait avec des logiques qui
reste des logiques parfois même très
mercantile au mépris d'un investissement
social important notamment auprès des
étudiants on va quitter juste la
thématique de l'université plus
globalement pour parler de la campagne
parce que la campagne qui se poursuit et
du côté de la droite du centre on a fait
des alliances pas ce qui n'est pas le
cas du côté de la gauche
est-ce que c'est pas un risque malgré
tout il ya toujours eu une diversité à
gauche moi je conduisais une liste déjà
aux élections régionales la dernière
fois une contexte actuel même je vous
interromps mais aussi la donne et du
front national par exemple qu'il y avait
plus que derrière il ya la diversité de
la gauche continue d'exister et ça ne
nous a pas empêchés et le fait d'avoir
commune
dernière fois de travailler dans une
majorité régionale qui a fait des
mesures extrêmement positive mais de
surcroît ce qui a changé aussi c'est en
ce moment c'est qu'à une politique
gouvernementale conduite par un
gouvernement socialiste qui ne convient
pas du tout qui ne correspond pas à ce
qu'attendent les gens gauche il faut
donc les gens de gauche puissent trouver
une liste dans ces élections qui
expriment leurs exigences sociales qui
expriment leur exigence d'égalité qui
expriment leurs exigences de mettre fin
aux logiques d'austérité qui font du mal
aux politiques publiques
c'est cette voie là que nous allons
porter au premier tour dans notre esprit
c'est très clairement pour faire gagner
des vraie politique de gauche au
deuxième tour en moi je n'ai aucune
envie d'avoir pécresse à la tête de la
région pas seulement parce qu'elle a
fait les lois qu'elle a fait dans le
domaine de l'université mais parce que
elle était conseillère régionale dans le
monde a écoulé moi aussi à chaque fois
qu'on a voulu prendre une mesure sociale
on avait systématiquement valérie
pécresse en face de nous donc je sais
que ce qu'elle a en tête ce qu'elle veut
faire dans la région qui est l' inverse
à mon avis de ce qu attendent beaucoup
de gens dans la région où on a besoin
d'égalité est pour ca de grandes
politiques publiques mais l'alliance
sera possible au deuxième tour malgré ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui vis-à-vis du
gouvernement on vous dit que la
politique du gouvernement ne vous
convient pas on peut citer un ensemble
pour faire une petite parenthèse une
illustration des thématiques sur les
quelque chose est ce que
on aura 2 2 en jeu on les a déjà
aujourd'hui il faut empêcher la droite
de prendre la direction de la région
mais il faut près il faut faire
prévaloir à gauche des choix politiques
courageux y compris face aux logiques
d'austérité du gouvernement
donc ce que vous dite à effet retard
s'est hâté porno pour changer à toi il
faut que notre liste ne soit pas une
liste d'appui au deuxième tour il faut
qu'elle soit une liste qui donne le ton
de la campagne de deuxième tour si elle
peut être renaître tant mieux si jamais
elle ne l'était pas il faut qu'elle soit
tellement haute que ces propositions
soient en contournable dans la
construction d'une future majorité de
gauche et parmi les différentes
propositions on ne pourra pas reprendre
tout le programme mais quelques points
peut-être on peut parler de la santé
pour important vous l'avait dit lors du
lancement officiel de votre campagne
la santé c'est une des grandes questions
ça n'est pas une compétence régionale
obligatoire mais en ile de france et
compte tenu du fait qu'aujourd'hui les
restructurations de la santé au lieu à
l'échelle de la région avec les ars où
nous pensons que la région va s'en mêler
et qu'il faut travailler à des
politiques d'égalité mais évidemment il
ya des enjeux de même nature dans le
domaine du service public du logement ou
détrôner un logement transport la
question du logement justement
l'encadrement des loyers par exemple ça
ce cadre des cotations priorité aussi au
logement étudiant es et à la priorité
pour la jeunesse dans le logement il
faut construire des logements
accessibles à ces jeunes et aux
étudiants données départ systématique
dans la construction des programmes à du
logement étudiant
parce que non seulement au manque de
logements étudiants mais même le
logement étudiant devient quelque part
un objet de spéculation on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de propriétaires ou des
multipropriétaires qui investissent pour
pouvoir faire de l'argent sur le
logement étudiant en tournée dans
l'aberration total et il faut reprendre
au mans ça et la politique d'encadrement
ayé peut être moyen de le faire puisque
moi je propose qu'on étende à l'ensemble
de la région ce qui a été fait à paris
on voit d'ores et déjà que ça permet une
pression à la baisse sur le niveau des
loyers une toute dernière question vous
voulez peser vous l'avais dit dans le
cadre d'une alliance au second tour une
alliance de la gauche l'objectif c'est
quoi 10% minimum du minimum
j'ai tout de suite dit aujourd'hui dans
les jours dont les analystes c'est à
dire on est dans les trois listes de
gauche la seule qui est donné aux
progrès significatif par rapport à ses
résultats de la dernière fois ça veut
dire qu'il ya ici il ya une dynamique à
gauche elle peut se créer autour de nos
pistes donc moi j'ai dit je ne fixe pas
de limites
pour moi le score à deux chiffres c'est
le minimum de ce qu'il faut essayer
d'obtenir mais essayons d'aller plus
haut possible
c'est ce qui peut permettre je pense une
victoire de la gauche au deuxième tour
dans l'île de france vous remercie alors
on quitte les régionales dans cette
édition du 7 8 politique pour revenir
sur ce déplacement du gouvernement dix
ans après les émeutes urbaines qui ont
embrasé la france manuel valls s'est
rendu à lundi 26 octobre mureaux dans le
cadre d'un comité interministériel à
l'égalité et à la citoyenneté le chef du
gouvernement accompagné de dix sept de
ses ministres a d'abord participé à une
visite de terrain du nouveau
commissariat mais aussi de la mission
locale avant de s'adresser à la presse
autour de différentes mesures qui ont
été annoncées williams elles étaient sur
place ce sont cinq nouvelles mesures qui
viennent désormais s'ajouter aux 60
annoncé en mars dernier lors du comité
interministériel à l'égalité et à la
citoyenneté
lors de sa conférence de presse aux
mureaux ce matin le premier ministre a
fait savoir la volonté du gouvernement
de reconnaître les obstacles auxquels
sont confrontés les habitants des
quartiers défavorisés les obstacles de
plusieurs natures
je les dis difficulté sociale qui
persiste discrimination en fois ça
s'appelle tout simplement du racisme qui
font des dégâts considérables sur les
destins individuels scolaire
professionnel stigmatisation à l'endroit
de l'islam alors que la deuxième
religion de france cherche sa place
notre société parmi ces cinq nouvelles
me
dur pour revaloriser ces quartiers
faciliter les relations entre les forces
de l'ordre et la population prévenir la
radicalisation et lutter contre les
discriminations beaucoup en parler
emploi accès à l'emploi créé son
entreprise l'accompagnement culture bref
tous les sujets sont abordés pour qui
une action publique globale qui fasse
que voilà on salue les quartiers comme
une chance c'est une chance dans ces
mesures également lutter contre la
ségrégation notamment dans le logement
et la construction d'habitat social ou
36 vie sont déjà pointés du doigt comme
la commune de maisons laffitte dans les
yvelines renforcer les sanctions contre
les nerfs refusant de construire des
logements sociaux en transférant aux
préfets leur compte agent municipal
d'attribution il faut que les choses
bougent et l'état emploi et emploiera
tous les moyens nécessaires
il prendra la main s'il le faut comme la
loi l'y autorise la dernière mesure
s'inscrit elle dans la continuité du
contrat de ville mise en oeuvre pour
rénover l'action publique dans les
quartiers et la rendre plus cohérente et
efficace annoncé ce matin la nomination
de délégués du gouvernement dans les
villes pour coordonner l'action des
services de l'état et ses opérations en
lien avec le préfet et le maire d'issy
deux pilotes ont déjà été choisies pour
cette mesure avec notamment la commune
de crap dans les yvelines le 7-8
politique se referme on se retrouve très
prochainement sur tv fil 78 excellente
soirée